[Musique]
les fêtes johanniques sont devenus au
fil du temps la vitrine d'orléans la
fierté de la population mais ce que tout
le monde les apprécie vraiment pour
autant que pense-t-on cette année du
calendrier chamboulé à cause du scrutin
présidentiel parole d'orléanais dans
c'est vous qui le dites
[Musique]
que pensez-vous des fêtes de jeanne
d'arc je pense que c'est une belle fête
populaire et ça permet de rencontrer les
orléanais dans l'air dans la rue
voir des gens qui comptent pas forcément
au quotidien super fait ça fait une très
grosse animation dans la ville d'orléans
ça draine énormément de monde alors que
pensez-vous des fêtes de jeanne d'arc
il faudrait peut-être
renouvelée
changer un peu quelque chose sur le
défilé des fêtes de jeanne d'arc parce
que
c'est un peu tous les ans la même chose
ça vous change et j'ai connu ça tout
gamin voilà donc c'est des choses qui
ont changé
c'est sympathique c'était comment
lorsque vous étiez enfant à c'était
beaucoup plus importants alors
connaissez vous le nom de la charme de
cette année est bien
un jeu l'élu dans le journal et
j'ai oublié son nom eh bien je les lui
dans le journal mais je ne mets pas
retenu alors il s'agit de priscille de
la bâtie l élève en seconde au lycée
jean zay orléans ça ne vous dérange pas
que les fêtes étaient décalés absolument
pas non pas du tout j'espère qu'il sera
beaucoup le temps sera avec nous mais ça
ne me dérange pas plus que ça non non
pas du tout non ça me dérange pas du
tout tout est décalé au cours d'une
semaine où s de l'élection
présidentielle voilà mais il n'y a pas
de fin pour moi ya pas de problème
c'était indispensable dans le sens où
oubliez les fêtes aux élections c'est
dommage ça aurait pu mieux c'était mieux
dissocier les deux je pense où on aurait
surtout surtout peut-être avancer la
date des élections d'une semaine voilà
c'était et c'est quelque chose qui était
l'effet de jeunes garçons toujours calé
d'année en année ce qui n'est pas le cas
de l'élection de l'élection
présidentielle driller nationale aurait
dû s'adapter au fait de jeu n'a en fait
je sors était banal
quel est pour vous le moment le plus
important des fêtes johanniques bas ce
qui m'a marqué le plus sûrement le
défilé l'entrée de jeanne dans la rue de
bourgogne et de défis liés déjà qui est
très important qui se vend à toute la
population
tout le chemin enfin c'est c'est
important le soir aussi la soirée alors
ce qu'on appelait avant l'embrasement
des tours donc cette soirée nocturne
c'est quelque chose que j'apprécie
particulièrement
personnellement ça fait partie d'une
chorale qui reçoit des commandes
étrangères au moment des fêtes de jeanne
d'arc ça permet aussi de rencontrer des
gens qui viennent de loin avec d'autres
cultures et est un échange très riche
toujours
mais cet électron vous entendre c'est
quoi ça a été changée de place c'est
très bien pourquoi ça a été mis
maintenant du côté du théâtre
je pense que pour drainer l'association
pour pour plein chaussettes sait si
c'est très bien c'était changer de place
j'ai été plusieurs fois au secteur il
trop j'ai bien aimé mais j'ai préféré
quand 1006 situé ici sur la place de
loire plutôt qu'au théâtre en fait moi
je n'y vais pas mais je trouve
intéressant de qui les fuit les jeunes
soient associés aussi à aux fêtes de
jeanne d'arc mais c'est une façon
d'associer tout le monde aux fêtes de
jeanne d'arc
alors je vais être très franc avec vous
j'ai jamais assisté au moindre set
électro depuis que ça existe aux fêtes
de jeanne d'arc voilà donc
vu le monde qui s'y qui s'y pressent je
pense que c'est une bonne chose mais moi
personnellement j'ai jamais assisté
vous avez tout ce qu'il faut